The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ALAN OPPENHEIM: Last
time we introduced
the notion of digital
networks and the general topic
of digital network theory.
There, of course, are
lots of directions
that that discussion
can proceed in,
but during this
set of lectures, we
won't be talking in any more
detail about the general issues
of digital network theory.
In this lecture and
the next lecture,
I would like to consider, in
particular, some of the more
common structures that
are used for implementing
digital filters--
first for the case of infinite
impulse response filters,
which we'll discuss in this
lecture, and then in the next
lecture some of the more common
structures for finite impulse
response digital filters.
To begin the discussion, let's
consider the most general form,
once again, for the
transfer function
of a digital filter
where we are assuming
that the system function H of
z is a rational function in z
to the minus 1.
We recall from our
previous discussions
that a rational transfer
function of this form
corresponds to a linear
constant coefficient difference
equation, and in particular,
the difference equation
corresponding to
this system function
is the difference equation
that I've indicated here.
The coefficients in the
numerator corresponding
to the polynomial
that represents
the 0's of the
transfer function are
identical to the
coefficients applied
to the delayed
values of the input,
and the coefficients in the
denominator corresponding
to the coefficients for
the polynomial representing
the poles are the
same coefficients,
which, in the
difference equation,
correspond to the
weights applied
to delayed values of the output.
So this is the general
form of a transfer function
for assuming that the system
is representable by a linear
constant coefficient
difference equation,
and the difference equation
corresponding to this transfer
function is as I've
indicated here.
Incidentally, let me stress as
I indicated in the last lecture
that our assumption will be
throughout these discussions
that we are discussing--
considering a causal system.
In other words, the
region of convergence
that we would associate
with this transfer function
is the region of
convergence that would
correspond to a causal system.
In other words, the
region of convergence
is outside the outermost pole.
There are a variety of ways in
which we can rewrite a transfer
function of this form.
One possible way of writing
this transfer function
is as I've indicated
at the bottom.
That is an expression
corresponding
to the product of
two functions--
the first representing
the polynomial
for the 0's, and the
second representing
the polynomial for the poles.
What this suggests is
that we can imagine
implementing this system by
implementing a system which
realizes this transfer
function, and cascading that--
the cascade leading
to the product
of the system functions--
cascading that with a system
that implements this system
function.
What that corresponds
to in the implementation
of the difference
equation is first
implementing in terms of
multipliers, delays, and adders
as we talked about last time--
implementing first
the linear combination
of the weighted
delayed input values,
and then using that as
the input to a system
which implements the weighted
delayed output values.
So implementing this system
function with this function
first in cascade with this
corresponds to implementing
this difference
equation where we
can imagine denoting this
first sum as x1 of n--
implementing x1 of n--
implementing the
function x1 of n,
and then using that as the
input to a system which
is represented by the
difference equation y of n
equals x1 of n plus this sum.
Carrying that out, the
digital network that results
is as I've indicated
here, where we have,
first of all, the
linear combination
of weighted delayed
input values.
So here is x of n, x of n
minus 1, x of n minus 2,
down through x of
n minus capital
N, where I'm assuming
in drawing this
that capital M is
equal to capital N.
This first block then implements
this summation to form x1 of n,
and then the second system
which this has cascaded with
has as an input
x1 of n and added
to it weighted delayed
values of the output.
So here is y of
n, y of n minus 1,
down through y of
n minus capital N.
We see the coefficients a1,
a2, through a sub capital N.
Clearly in this implementation
this block corresponds
to implementing the
zeros of the system,
and this block corresponds
to implementing
the poles of the system.
So as we've factored the
transfer function into the 0's
followed by the poles,
we have this system
implementing the 0's followed
by this system implementing
the poles.
Well, this, of course,
is one implementation
of the difference equation,
but in fact, there
are a variety of ways in which
we can manipulate the transfer
function, or, equivalently,
in which we can manipulate
the difference equation, which
will lead to other structures
for implementing the system
besides the structure
that I've indicated here.
Well, let's consider one simple
way of manipulating this system
to generate another structure.
We recognize this as
two systems in cascade.
They both implement linear
shift invariant systems,
and we know that two
linear shift invariant
systems in cascade can be
cascaded in either order
without affecting
the overall transfer
function of the system.
So we can imagine just
simply breaking the system
at this point,
interchanging the order
in which these two
systems are cascaded,
and obviously what
that leads to is
a second implementation of
the same difference equation.
That implementation
in particular,
whereas this one has the zeros
first followed by the poles--
interchanging the
order of those two
will result in the
poles implemented first,
followed by the
0's, and the system
that results is what I've
indicated on this next view
graph.
So this system is
identical to the other one.
It's clearly identical in
terms of the overall transfer
function, and what
I've done simply
is just to interchange the order
in which the 0's and the poles
are implemented.
Well, that manipulation
that is breaking that system
and interchanging the order in
which the systems are cascaded
can be interpreted in terms
of either a manipulation
on the transfer function or a
manipulation on the difference
equation, and to indicate
what that corresponds
to let's return to the
general difference equation
as we had it on the
first view graph--
the transfer
function, where now,
rather than cascading this
system first and this system
second, we've simply
interchanged the order in which
those two systems are cascaded.
That's interpreting
this operation in terms
of the transfer function.
To interpret it in terms
of the difference equation
is slightly more involved,
but basically and very quickly
what it involves is first
implementing the difference
equation in which we consider
that the input is just x of n
rather than a weighted sum of
delayed x of n's to implement
to implement the output y1 of n.
And then since the input is,
in fact, a linear combination
of weighted delayed inputs,
the corresponding output
is the same linear combination
of weighted delayed outputs.
That essentially is derived
from using properties
of linear shift
invariant systems
that we talked about and
some of the early lectures.
Well, returning to
the network that
resulted by interchanging the
order of these two systems, one
of the questions we
can ask, of course,
is whether there
is any advantage
to implementing this system
rather than implementing
the first system
that we derived.
And in answering that,
one thing that we
notice about this system is that
there are two parallel branches
here with corresponding delays.
Now, what does that mean?
Well, if we consider this
output to be y1 of n--
it's the y1 of n that we had
defined in the previous slide--
the value appearing
here is y1 of n minus 1,
but the value appearing
here is y1 of n minus 1.
The value appearing here is y1
of n minus 2 and appearing here
is y1 of n minus 2.
And in fact, following this
chain down, what we observe
is that the output of this
delay is exactly the same
as the output of this delay.
Well, if that's the case,
then in fact there obviously,
if we think about
an implementation,
is no reason to separately
store this delayed output
and this delayed output
since they're the same.
In other words, we can
collapse these delays together,
and the network
that results when
we do that is the network that
I indicate here, where all
that I've done in going from
the previous network to this one
is simply collapse
the delays together,
taking advantage of the
fact that their outputs
were identical.
Now, in drawing a
network, of course,
it doesn't particularly
matter whether we conserve
z to the minus 1's or
equivalently whether we
collapse a network when we
can take advantage of the fact
that the output of two
delays is the same,
but clearly in terms
of implementation
of a digital filter either
in terms of a program
or in terms of special
purpose hardware,
obviously clearly there's
an advantage to reducing
the number of delay registers
that are required, because you
see each z to the
minus 1 that appears
in the structure requires
in the implementation
a register to store the value--
in other words, to hold
it for the next iteration.
So in this structure, as
it's implemented here,
we have n delay
registers, where again I'm
assuming that capital M was
equal to capital N. There are
N delay registers, whereas
in the first network
that we generated--
the network corresponding to the
0's first and then the poles--
the there were two
M delay registers.
In general, a digital
filter structure
that has the minimum
number of delay
registers-- and you can
show that the minimum number
required is the
greater of M or N,
or since we're
considering M equal to N,
the minimum number
is N. The structure
that has only that
minimum number
and no more is
generally referred
to as a canonic structure.
So the structure that
I've indicated here
is a canonic structure.
It has the minimum
number of delays,
but in fact, it's not the
only canonic structure.
There are a large variety
of canonic structures,
and in fact, there's
a canonic structure
that is similar to
the first structure
that we derived in the
sense that it also has--
is implemented with the 0's
first, followed by the poles.
Let me remind you again that
this system as it's implemented
is basically a cascade
of the system poles.
Those are the a's--
or the polynomial
that this implements
corresponds to the poles--
followed by an implementation of
the 0's, and it's the b's that
control the 0's.
Well, to generate
another canonic structure
we can take advantage
of a theorem
that, in fact, is a very
powerful theorem in dealing
with filter structures--
the theorem, which
is referred to
as the transposition theorem.
What the transposition
theorem says
is that, if we have a network
that implements a transfer
function, and if we simply
reverse the direction of all
of the branches in the
network and we interchange
the input and the
output, then the transfer
function that results
is exactly the same.
So it says take the network,
reverse the direction
of the branches, put the
input where the output was,
take the output
where the input was,
and what you find is that the
transfer function of the system
is exactly the same.
Well, let me illustrate
this theorem.
We won't incidentally
prove the theorem,
although in the notes in the
text at the end of the chapter
there, in fact, is a proof
of the transposition theorem,
but let me illustrate the
transposition theorem--
first with a simple
example that makes it
appear to be a trivial
theorem, and then
with another example
that suggests
that perhaps the theorem is less
obvious than it would at first
appear.
Well, to illustrate the
transposition theorem,
let's begin with
a simple network--
just a simple first
order network,
two coefficient branches
and a delay branch.
The transposition theorem
says that we want first of all
to reverse the direction
of all of the branches.
So this branch gets
turned around, again,
with a gain of unity.
This branch gets turned
around with a gain of c.
around with a gain of a.
The delay branch
is turned around.
This branch, which has a gain
of unity, is turned around.
Put the input where the output
was, and take the output
from where the input was.
So the transpose of this
network is the network
that I've indicated here,
and now of course we
can redraw this
network by putting
the input on the left hand
side and taking the output
on the right hand side.
That is taking the
same network and just
flipping it over-- flipping
it over because we tend
to have a convention that
the input is coming in
from the left and the output
is going out at the right.
If we do that, just
taking this network
and simply flipping
it over, we have
x of n coming in
through a unity gain.
This delay has now ended
up on the left hand side,
and you can verify in
a straightforward way
that these branches are
now correct if we just take
this network and flip it over.
And is it true that the transfer
function of this network
is identical to the transfer
function of this network?
Well, you should be able
to see by inspection
that in fact it is true.
In fact, if you compare
this network to this one,
what's the only difference?
The only difference is that this
delay, instead of being here,
ended up on the other side of
the coefficient multiplier.
And obviously since
these two in cascade
implement a times
z to the minus 1,
it doesn't matter whether
I do the multiplication
by a first and then
delay or the reverse.
So applying the transposition
theorem to this simple example,
we see that obviously
for this example
the transposition theorem works.
Well, let's try it on a slightly
more complicated example
not to verify that it works,
but just again to emphasize
how the transposition
is implemented.
Here I have an example in which
I have a canonic first order
system.
This implements
one 0 and one pole.
Here is the
implementation of the pole
and the implementation of the 0.
This, in fact, is the
first order counterpart
of the canonic structure that I
showed several view graphs ago.
And so it's one pole,
and that's implemented
through this loop,
one 0, and that's
implemented through this loop.
And these, of course,
are unity gain
since I put no
amplitude on them.
And now to apply the
transposition theorem
to this network, again, we
interchange the-- we reverse
the direction of
all of the arrows,
and you can see that I've done
that in all of these branches.
The delay is likewise reversed.
The a is reversed,
and the b is reversed.
I put the input in
where the output was.
I take the output out
where the input was,
and then the
transposition theorem
says that this first
order system implements
exactly the same transfer
function as this first order
system does.
Well, again, we can redraw
this by taking again the input
at the left hand
side, the output
at the right hand side that
corresponds to just taking
this and flipping it over.
In fact, I could do that
by taking the view graph
and just flipping it
over, and the result then,
just flipping this
over, is the system
that I've indicated here--
x of n in at the left
hand side, y of n
out at the right hand side.
And now in comparing
these two there
are some changes
that took place.
In particular, we notice
that the direction
of the delayed
branch is reversed.
Furthermore, whereas this system
implemented the pole first
followed by the 0, this
system implements the 0 first,
followed by the pole.
Is this still a
canonic structure?
Well, of course it's
a canonic structure
because it only has one
delay, and obviously, in fact,
transposing a network
couldn't possibly
affect the number of
delays in the network
so that, if we begin
with a canonic structure
and apply the transposition
theorem to it,
we must end up with a
canonic structure also.
Well, it shouldn't be obvious--
or, at least it isn't
obvious to me by inspection--
that this system and this
system have the same transfer
function, but in
fact you can verify
that in a very simple
and straightforward way
by simply calculating what the
transfer functions of these two
systems are.
Well, returning then to the
general canonic structure
that we had, we can generate
a second canonic structure
by applying the transposition
theorem to this structure.
That is reversing the
directions of all of the arrows,
putting the input in here, and
taking the output out there,
and then to keep our convention
of the input in at the left,
the output out at
the right, flip
that over to generate a second
canonic structure, which
is the transpose
of this structure.
And if we do that, the
two changes to focus on
is that the direction of the
delayed branches is reversed,
and furthermore, the system
will implement the 0's first,
followed by the poles.
In fact, the
network that results
is what I've indicated here.
This is then the transposed
version of the structure
that I just showed on
the last view graph.
The 0's are implemented here.
The poles are implemented
here, and the direction
of the delayed
branches is reversed,
but again, this is a
canonic form structure.
So some structures are
canonic form, and some aren't.
The first one, in
fact, that we developed
wasn't canonic form in the
sense that it had more delays
than were absolutely necessary.
The last two structures
that we've shown
are canonic form structures
in that they have
the minimum number of delays.
All of these
structures are referred
to as direct form structures--
direct form because
they are structures
that involve as
coefficients in them
the same coefficients that
are present in the difference
equation describing
the overall system.
Recall again that these were the
coefficients in the difference
equation which were applied
to the delayed values
of the input, and these were the
coefficients in the difference
equation that were applied to
delayed values of the output.
And this structure and
the other structures
involving the
coefficients in that form
are often referred to as
direct form structures.
Well, these structures are fine
for implementing the difference
equation, although there
are other structures--
actually there are essentially
an infinite variety
of structures, but there are
some other structures that
in some situations are better
to use than the direct form
structures, and two
of the more common,
which I'd like to introduce
now, are the cascade structure
and the parallel structure.
The cascade structure
is developed basically
by factoring the transfer
function of the system
into a product of second
order sections or second order
factors.
In particular, we have,
again, the general form
of the transfer function--
H of z as the numerator
polynomial for the 0's,
a denominator polynomial
for the poles.
We can factor the
numerator polynomial
into a product of first order
polynomials and the denominator
polynomial into a product
of first order polynomials.
In general, of course, these
factors will be complex,
and these factors
will be complex.
We can combine together the
complex conjugate 0 pairs
and the complex
conjugate pole pairs
so that in fact as a
general cascade form
it's often convenient to think
of a factorization of each
of these polynomials into
second order polynomials rather
than first order polynomials.
Carrying that out, we end
up with a representation
of the transfer function in a
form as I've indicated here--
a second order numerator
polynomial and a second order
denominator polynomial,
and, of course,
it's the product
of these that we
use to implement
this overall transfer
function with some
constant multiplier
out in front, which is required
essentially because we've
normalized these polynomials
to have a leading
coefficient of unity.
Well, first of all, why
might we want to do this?
There actually are a variety
of reasons for perhaps wanting
to consider an implementation
of the transfer function
in terms of a cascade
of lower order
systems than the general
n-th order system.
One of the more
common reasons, which
I'll have more to
say about actually
at the end of the
next lecture, but I'd
like to at least
allude to it now,
is the fact that any time
we implement a system
on a digital computer or with
special purpose hardware we're
faced with the problem that
these coefficients can't
be represented exactly.
If we have, let's say, an
18 bit fixed point register,
we're restricted to
truncating or rounding
these coefficients to 18 bits.
If we implement a filter and
special purpose hardware,
we might want the
coefficient registers
to be as low as 4, or
5, or 6, or 10 bits.
Obviously, the more
bits, the more expensive
the hardware implementation is.
And the statement which
I'll make and justify
in a little more detail at
the end of the next lecture
is that, if I implement
the poles of the system
through a high order polynomial,
errors in the coefficients
lead to large errors in
the pole locations as
compared with an implementation
of the poles in terms
of low order polynomials.
That is, basically
the sensitivity
of pole locations to
errors in the coefficients
is higher the higher the
order of the polynomial.
Consequently, if that indeed
is an issue for the filter
implementation,
then it is better
to implement a system as
a cascade of lower order
systems or lower
order polynomials
then as one large
high order polynomial.
So factoring this
transfer function
into a cascade of second order
sections, what this leads
to is an implementation
of the system as a cascade
of second order
systems, and we, again,
have the choice of
implementing each second order
section in a variety
of ways corresponding
to the various direct forms that
we've talked about previously.
One implementation, which
is a canonic direct form,
is the implementation
that I indicate here,
where this is alpha 1,1,
the coefficient alpha 1,1,
the coefficient beta 1,1.
It's a little hard to see where
each of these coefficients
goes, but this is a canonic
form implementation of a second
order section that has
two poles and two 0's.
So as I've implemented it, I've
implemented it with the poles
first, followed by
the 0's, and then this
is one second order piece that's
in cascade with the next pole 0
pair, with the next
pole 0 pair, et cetera.
So this is a cascade of
second order sections,
and, of course, I can generate
other cascade forms was
one possibility by just simply
applying the transposition
theorem to this cascade, and
basically what would result
is that each of
these delay branches
would be reversed in
direction, and the 0's
would be implemented first,
followed by the poles.
Generally what's meant though
by the cascade structure,
and you can see again that
there are a variety of cascade
structures depending
on how you choose
to implement the pole 0 pairs--
what is generally meant
by the cascade structure
or a cascade structure is an
implementation of the transfer
function is a cascade
of second order sections
where the second order
sections can be implemented
in a variety of ways.
Another structure which is like
the cascade structure in that
it implements the poles in
terms of low order sections,
but is different in
the way effectively
that it realizes the zeros is
the so-called parallel form
structure.
And the parallel form structure
can be implemented by--
can be derived by
expanding the transfer
function of the system in
terms of a partial fraction
expansion.
That is, we can expand this
transfer function in terms of--
and let's assume first
of all the capital
M is less than capital
N. If capital M were less
than capital N, we
can expand this simply
as a sum of residues together
with first order poles,
or in general since
the poles are complex,
we can imagine factoring this
in terms of first order terms
corresponding to the real
poles, and then second order
terms where we combine together
first order terms which
are complex conjugates so
that we have second order
terms of this form.
If capital M is
less than capital N,
those are the only
two kinds of terms
that would result in a
partial fraction expansion.
If capital M is greater
than or equal to capital N,
then we'll have additional
terms corresponding simply
to weighted powers
of z to the minus 1.
Now, as in the cascade form,
generally the parallel form
structure is
considered to be one
where even if we
have real poles we
combine two of the
real poles together
to implement the system in
terms of second order sections.
If we do that, then the parallel
form expansion for the transfer
function is what
I've indicated here,
where combining two terms
of this form together,
or, equivalently, looking
at expansions of this form,
we have a numerator polynomial
implementing a single 0
and a denominator polynomial
implementing two poles.
And then depending on whether
M is greater than capital N
or not, there might
be additional terms
involving simple weighted
values of z to the minus--
weighted powers of
z to the minus 1.
Let me stress that there are
some differences between this
and the cascade form obviously.
One of the differences
is that the sections used
for implementing the
filter consist of one 0
plus two poles,
and then the output
is formed not as a cascade
of sections of that type,
but as a sum of the outputs of
sections of that type since H
of z here is expressed as a
sum of second order sections,
whereas in the
cascade form it is
expressed as a product
of second order sections.
Well, the general filter
structure that results I've
indicated here for
the case in which we
have three second
order sections,
and again, I'm assuming that
capital M is equal to capital N
so that we have one branch,
which is just simply
a coefficient branch.
If capital M was one
more than capital N,
we would have in addition
to that one delay branch.
And then we have
second order sections
as I've indicated here,
but the second order
sections implement only a
single 0 and a pair of poles--
a single 0 and a pair of poles.
Now, why might you want
to use a parallel form
implementation instead of a
cascade form implementation?
Well, there actually
are several reasons.
One of the most common,
in fact, though,
is that sometimes in applying
filter design techniques
the filter design
parameters are automatically
generated in a parallel form.
That is, rather
than being generated
either as a ratio of polynomials
or as poles and 0's, it
might be generated in terms
of residues and poles.
In that case, of course,
it's very straightforward
to go to a parallel form
implementation rather than
a cascade form implementation.
Basically the difference
between the two forms
is that the cascade
form implements
in terms of low order sections
poles and 0's of the system,
whereas the parallel form
implementation is effectively
an implementation of the
system in terms of the poles.
The poles are controlled in
the same way as they were
in the cascade structure, but
poles and residues rather than
poles and 0's.
Again, with the
parallel form structure,
we can generate other
parallel form structures
by considering other ways of
implementing the second order
sections.
One possibility is to apply
the transposition theorem,
and in fact, there are other
implementations of second order
sections, and so we can
talk about a variety
of parallel form structures,
but generally when
we refer to a parallel form or
the parallel form structures,
we generally mean a
parallel realization
of poles in terms of
second order sections
and a weighting applied that
correspond to the residues.
Now, the topic of
digital filter structures
is, in fact, a very
complicated topic.
There are a lot of
other filter structures
which can be used for
implementing recursive filters,
or non-recursive filters, or
a finite impulse response,
or infinite impulse response.
There are structures referred
to as continued fraction
structures.
There are structures referred
to as interpolation structures.
to as lattice structures,
and ladder
structures, et cetera.
There are a large variety
of structures, and in fact,
one of the very important
issues currently is the design
and development of
structures and the comparison
of structures in particular
focusing on the trade-offs--
that is, the advantages
and disadvantages--
between various structures.
The structures that
I've introduced here--
that is, the direct form,
the canonic form, cascade,
and parallel--
are the most common
structures which are used.
They, in fact, tend
to hold up very well
and seem to be for
a variety of reasons
some of the more
advantageous structures.
While I've presented this
discussion from a general point
of view and tended to focus
on infinite impulse response
transfer functions,
obviously these structures
can be applied to finite impulse
response or infinite impulse
response systems.
In the next lecture,
I'd like to continue
the discussion of structures
by focusing specifically
on finite impulse
response systems
and directing our attention to
some specific structures that
apply only to find
an impulse response
and take advantage of
some particular aspects
of finite impulse
response systems.
Thank you.